تشهد معارك الازمه الاوكرانيه تقلبات
عديده تسببت بهزيمه طرف في حال نقص
الذخيره ونصر الطرفا اخر في حال وفره
السلاح لذلك توجهنا الى اطراف مدينه
مارينكا المحتدمه بالمعارك لرصد مزيد من
الاخبار حول الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد مع
بدء الهجمات المضاده الاوكرانيه في مناطق
مختلفه من مقاطعه دانياسك ارتفعت وتيره
القصف المتبادل ما بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والجيش الروسي ومع اقترابنا من هذه
المناطق التي تعتبر اطراف مدينه مارينكا
ذات المعارك الساخنه والمحتدمه ما بين
الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه العوده بهجمات مضاده ومحاوله
استرجاع
كان قد سيطر عليها جيش الروسي سابقا
ومع احتدام هذه المعارك بين جيشين الروسي
والاوكراني يحاول الجيش الروسي اتخاذ
وسيله الدفاع بعد ان تاكد من وصول الاسلحه
والذخيره الى ايدي المقاتلين الاوكراني من
مدينه مارنكا التقينا مع المقاتلين في هذا
المحور
تحت سيطرتنا مساحات كبيره هنا اما بخصوص
الهجوم مضاده ومحاوله استرجاع اراضي كان
قد سيطر عليها جيش الروسي سابقا
ومع احتدام هذه المعارك بين جيشين الروسي
والاوكراني يحاول الجيش الروسي اتخاذ
وسيله الدفاع بعد ان تاكد من وصول الاسلحه
والذخيره الى ايدي المقاتلين الاوكراني من
مدينه مارينكا التقينا مع المقاتلين في
هذا المحور
تحت سيطرتنا مساحات كبيره هنا اما بخصوص
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الذي تعلن عنه
كياف استطيع القول انها دعايه اكثر من
الحقيقه حيث نتعرض لهجمات في عده جبهات
باستمرار وهذه طبيعه المعارك والحروب وبكل
الاحوال نصد الهجمات ونتقدم ببطء لعده
امتار يوميا لانهم يتحصلون جيدا ومستعدون
ومجهزون لكننا نتقدم ولو ببطء ونحن واثقون
من النصر وقريبا سنحرر مدينه مارينكا
بالكامل
من خطوط الجبهه الاماميه ومن خنادق القوات
الروسيه حيث الدبابات والمدافع التي تطلق
من حولنا هنا
نرصد العربيه والحدث والمعارك التي تدور
في اطراف مارنكا
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر
مارينكا دانياسك لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات